with less than a year to go until
crucial European parliamentary elections
French president Emmanuel macron party
has suffered a setback losing support to
the far-right a recent poll suggests
marine lepen 's populist national rally
party could win as much as 17 percent of
the french vote that's not far behind
macrons on marsh party whose support has
now slipped to 20%
well the trend isn't unique to France in
neighboring Germany far-right support
has also seen a spike on the back of
stronger anti-immigrant sentiment last
weekend's the murder of a man is
suspected by two migrants sparked a
series of rowdy mass demonstrations in
the city of Chemnitz support for the
far-right AFD party has since surged and
it's currently Germany's second largest
political force meanwhile a new study
suggests that women are a significant
driving force behind the swing to the
right as RT Charlotte Dubinsky explains
across Europe right-wing parties have
been gaining ground over the last few
years this so-called rise of the right
has caused much angst amongst political
rivals and now
one study written for a political
foundation in Germany seems to have put
its finger on what's really the problem
women as apparently it's a trend of
women becoming increasingly lured to
right-wing political parties women
voters were long thought to be
relatively immune to the election
policies advocated by right-wing
populist and right-wing extremist
parties the question is why women become
involved in these parties at all whether
it's because of women voters or not what
seems certain when you look at the polls
is that here in France the gap between
Mekons lack of public or marsh party and
the Pens national rally is getting
narrower much narrower well so are women
moving towards the right and if they are
is it at all surprising prospects are
swayed to a norm I don't think that it's
surprising because
political leaders in power before come
from the party which absolutely didn't
react to understand the phenomenon of
voters shifting rights we need to look
in context with growing insecurity we
have massive immigration rise of
Islamism I see this as a reaction to all
these problems for more than 15 years
the researchers have been looking at the
National Front in France recently
rebranded as the national rally to see
what attracts women to them the authors
concluded that often they simply poorly
understood their party's electoral
proposals at auction fashion I am a
woman I am young I live in the Paris
suburbs I think I am at the heart of the
problem which means that when I leave
home I know what it's like to get mean
stairs be insulted over what I wear I'm
really facing these problems I know how
it is to have your car burned a scooter
stolen dig a little further and you find
that the group behind the study is
affiliated with the SPD the German
Social Democratic Party as such much of
the work focusing on Germany looked at
comparing the performance of the SPD to
the anti-immigration anti-eu party the
AFD last September when the AFD got
record results getting into Parliament
for the very first time the election was
a bit of a damp squib for the SPD who
lost 40 seats so the authors treated
this as a bitter lesson for me
progressive and feminist viewpoint it
seems impossible that a woman in Germany
would vote AFD
and yet it happens so why did the AFD
see such a rise in support and why did
women vote for them conservative branch
has very constant has a very traditional
approach to women in my view women in
the traditional views can have many
roles and if
check into it you will find more elderly
women like myself for instance who after
they have been raising children and
running a family then start to get a new
role in politics even the study title
the triumph of women question mark could
be seen as a warning in itself as it
appears to allude to the title of a Nazi
Party propaganda film entitled the
triumph of the will which chronicled the
1934 Congress of the Nazi Party yet both
the women that we spoke to felt that
questioning of women triumphing with
right or with left-wing movements is not
an issue at all
no they affirm the triumph of women I
don't think it's necessary I think it's
more important to talk about triumph of
our ideas and triumph or France as
that's what prevails today we should not
think in these terms
male or female woman or man I think it's
up to the individual
you